et c'est mon dieu
je vais quitter thierry est quoi
tu veux qu'on sépare c'est d'accord mais
avant ce fait un dernier voyage aux
familles alten au part en vacances on se
refait grèce 81 18 si on veut pas c'est
hyper gentil papa mais ça va être
compliqué pour nous je sais pas si vous
savez thierry mais maintenant vous êtes
à la retraite des droits pas mal de
réduction si tu viens de te filmer le
roux et qui enchaîne sur ibiza en train
de marten 1500 les prix du kwh date ce
n'est pas un brouillage monsieur c'est
une reconquête larron frère comme ça
les enfants régler vos montres on est en
98 a les photos photos sympas les
vacances son camion poubelle bienvenus
l'annoncé n'a pas changé comme nous ce
tombeau
alema
un rendez vous
voilà le type est pour le moment
les mêmes vacances qu'il ya 20 ans la
même magie c'est un acteur porno rocco
siffredi oui votre cul pardon
moi ça me dérange la norme entier on a
décidé qu'on séparer
[Musique]
et là on joue la comédie de la famille
unie c'est ridicule c'est ce que tu fais
je profite on est séparé madame je passe
après monsieur next
surpris
à fameux kit les enfants pensent que je
suis un vieux con
c'est un sans faute
y'a aucun mal à créer des souvenirs mais
le meilleur souvenir ça doit rester le
prochain
[Musique]